also going bros my name is ben back
welcome back to add on just you get out
of here
shining throughout the intro the cruel
ways of a missus share what are you
doing mr. chair don't try to hide hey
everyone I was just sleeping that's how
share sleeps like this alright actually
I need you mr. chair I think the key is
up here if I'm oh oh of course you need
me I'm alright this is how I must [ __ ]
is supposed to find that I don't know
it's a big map that could have hinted it
to you Alaba what oh yeah miss Jeff huh
huh Oh No alright that's your in here
fantastic what is this a plate shot I
love play charts I love this - ello what
is that is that oil for me thank you
very much whoever put that let's see
wine cellar all right lass house sounds
good but doesn't it look very good to be
honest how I don't know why I wouldn't
be honest about that all right
Oh naked pictures okay this just keeps
getting better and better doesn't it
let's have a good look at a penis okay
that's enough penis for today
hey the acid John I want to remember
when I puts the following that
good times good stands means the
fountain just became friends and I
decided to put him in the acid joy all
right naked gasps oh my god are you
[ __ ] serious
you know that's not how you do it oh my
oh wow just wow let me help you with
that let me help you with that mission I
think this is how you pump it that must
hurt a must feel don't die or you will
end up like these guys they all didn't
pass my sesame oh no I definitely don't
want to end up like that guy all right
[Music]
okay let's try not dying because I don't
want to hae-jin about this all right
let's put that thing out of the way hey
hey hey pity how you doing
I looking for you you know I really like
your videos PD I'm a big fan I'm but I
only like my staff Jesus all right so
what's down here actually it's gotta be
something I said except naked guys Oh
what the [ __ ] was that
oh man Wow she's nice newschnoz what the
hell is this kind of map to saying oh
whatever
all right so we actually have to be
it's down here for shizzle what the hell
was that hurt my nipples I heard when I
trust them it's gotta be some secret
hatch or something
it's up cogwheel how you doing oh let's
talk to him how you doing hey he dangles
leg hey you like that yeah to the left
to the left everything you own in a box
to the left this torso is sexy I just
want to lick it oh it's gotta be
something where is that well it's the
key or though hey Jennifer
you got another secret for me get out of
here get out of here get ID you daddy
I come on I don't even know anymore
maybe behind him what is the secrets
what is this is Toledo I love oil make
sure that was a lie maybe behind this
bookshelf
tricky stuff man hey I did not mean to
light you you are one lucky flame thing
up here I don't know what I'm doing here
and jump to the barrel Hey
holy [ __ ] I am a genius finding a lot of
ketchup - that's good yay three sixes
[ __ ] yeah yeah that was more than 360
but whatever all right let's see what
adventure lies beyond this hatch thing
let's climb down oh that's convenient I
should climb down very carefully very
carefully
one cannot oh god its water San Juan de
indias hello okay so far no water
monster
all right I prefer singing on these
anyway Hades says Jesus talked to me ah
he's ignoring us
get up get up hey drugs come here drugs
yeah I love drugs okay okay I don't know
where to go
let's try this place oh of course you
need the key
yay finally with using this Oh God
nope I hate this let's fire protection I
have a box I have a box [ __ ] you
better not do anything Hey okay okay
nothing left to say doctor Jones Jones
calling doctor oh you're drowning you're
drowning you draw it they float never
mind
ah okay all right what's that huh what's
going on here
what the hell nuts mouse pad something
oh my god okay okay yeah there look what
they did to me oh my god they cut me in
half why do they keep telling me in half
oh my god that's a balance oh my god
tickets oh I know Panda hey they give me
a hug I love you so much baby what are
you doing pity
no don't do it today I don't do it it's
not worth it there there I love you and
we could have been married we could have
been gone to Las Vegas and just get
married but I did it with you I'm sorry
but I have to do it I have to shame
myself Hayley I don't want to be eaten I
don't but you already in half oh I
didn't I don't care
I'm sorry looking spinning for you I'm
spinning for you I don't care stop
spinning okay it's impressive it's
impressive but you have to go clear day
your sign up a bit I'd slime away
let's slime away richest new slime away
thank you guys every organic plans are
living for I just love slime away
alright that boil yes I have someone
glad that I'm like can I throw in his
legs too
I didn't eat it eat it huh what's going
on here
where is he I do not appreciate
hey above it bacon thank the bunny it's
delicious and nutritious okay that's
nice the finally when you need that
son-of-a-bitch
thank the stars the place in ass place
Jesus Christ
ah alright let's keep going
yep keep on calling everything up
Oh No Oh No now they trick Mac ah god
damn okay keep on keep on running keep
on keep on running keep on rolling go
did he give up oh no no he did not give
up
kristin is where the [ __ ] did you stay
oh god what the [ __ ] was that stop it
set up
that's a [ __ ] robot up it decides to
jump
hey nice do it again can you jump again
do it do it yes there you go alright
effect against any oh I know I know I
know I caused why of calls
hey go up Jesus Christ they never listen
to it how the hell am I supposed
stop it's not funny it's really really
how the hell I have to
oh the crowbar scared me a lot oh you
should not be able to come here okay
stop racing okay ah ah come on
this is [ __ ] [ __ ]
ah I need to fill myself up there open
that and then this is [ __ ] stupid I
found some stupid stop [ __ ] crowbar I
can carry this yet
and all the help I can me I mean yeah
alright this should be enough don't fall
I know it's one more give me that give
it a human a human egg duties
kinda hard to commentate one [ __ ] all
right no oh okay like a boss you're like
no don't press the ladder don't know
thank God I [ __ ] back on science stop
all right that was it
[ __ ] [ __ ] all right it's okay I got
this now let's finish this [ __ ] mess
I'm sorry
hey but first we must look at the penis
enjoy the penis should let it sink into
you all right we are finished
I need some follow again Jesus Christ
when he came down from the frigging I
don't even know anymore
I don't even freaking now get out of
here hey mr. Chet panty I was so worried
I'm so glad you're all right
I'm glad too mrs. Shay I'm sorry you
couldn't come with me actually I'm not
that sorry anyway I'm sorry but you have
to go there you have to save the
princess what [ __ ] princess are you
talking about I would have just got it a
kitchen pity it's obvious there's a girl
there if you know what I mean if you
know what I'm chair more accurate okay
all right let's keep on trolling
all right yeah yeah let's keep our load
badass get that okay one does this I
hate all of you I'm poop ha ha a book
I'm so freakin pumped yi yi yi
uh-huh uh-huh hey Petey how you doing I
just want to introduce you to my all my
friends all right you already met them
anyway I'm pumped me and the barrels had
a party wait you had a party with him
I'm just kidding with ya they were
uninvited but I was like no no Peter
doesn't like barrels so I'm not gonna
let me all right this one party too hard
he got a freaking cell into him oh and
before that pity we had some fun I had
the the you know you know the table
slide it feels so good you should try it
sometime
I fish oh yeah oh that feels good when I
get stuck my pen oh yeah the table slide
I could just do that I could just do
that all night long pity and it's so
much fun and then we bought we got
hungry so we got a bunch of potatoes as
you can see but we didn't eat them we
just we just slide at our naked buddies
on top of them like this mm-hmm
yeah potatoes
all right that's very interesting to me
yeah yeah you wanna come join me now
really yeah yeah I like this alright I'm
officially creeped out a little bit so I
like to do all right but you know if you
ever want to party with those pretty is
that cool or not all right I need to
find the key here that you know where
the key is no all right that's a lot of
glasses and that's Jesus Jesus do you
know what the keys sir chewiness oh my
god that's the father
LSP they are not golden editions to
follow but they do know where the key is
listen carefully pop what are you doing
payday I don't talk to barrels
okay I don't even hey did that piggy
just [ __ ] out a dog head that's [ __ ]
awesome
is it here maybe yes no I didn't even
burn my head finger this game has a lot
of [ __ ] keys all right let's continue
which way
Lulla Lulla no kinky lonely cough cough
Ilana be pinky body hula dual it off at
the pattern piece path 54 anchor yeah
yeah hey mr. Cheryl you don't have here
I don't like the stuff
hello all right we get know what's going
on the air together what if we got there
what does this say receptor septic
Coulomb I have no idea what that is
there are barrels hey Alice bidding we
meet again I waited a long time for you
Jesus Christ you just get lost
everywhere you just can't they get
anything done without me and you keep
smashing me that's all right though all
right I don't know what we're doing here
either sir [ __ ] barrels everywhere
man we need to find something here it's
like he's [ __ ] the barrels get out of
here or something I don't know
he hasn't even tricky [ __ ] hiding
spot since never ever made he is
definitely night not nice I don't see
any keys all right filly let's just keep
on looking at the other car the eyes
Jesus Christ pity you never can do
anything without me you know I am like
your eye if you are
Juliet than I am Romeo no the opposite I
am Jordan what never nothing okay I just
think you should adapt all right nothing
in that drawer this way bidding
okay the obvious stuff all right oh no I
don't like the situation one bit
chessy barrels so I'm gonna take one of
you get out ahead battles go is it safe
alright baby I can shake go it's safe
baby
all right I trust you
I never trusted you anyway I'm
definitely all right I did it
prison okay so my guess we need to find
another one of those [ __ ] keys and my
guess is that it's in the reception but
do you want inside pretty Estefan all
right I'll do it
see you tomorrow Bruce next time we'd
find a friggin key I suppose all right
here comes the brofist that was
[Music]
all right thank my son I'm just gonna
hit this thing don't anything stop yes
all your friends are gone in the other
dimension ah they're not gone yet you
had one body why didn't you are my god